Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
I appreciate it.
Well, guys, tonight
in Washington, D.C.,
President Biden attended
the 99th annual National
Christmas Tree Lighting.
Meanwhile the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree was like,
"Uh, yeah, sure, that's
the national Christmas tree."
And this was special.
A real-life Elf on the Shelf
made an appearance.
Yeah, he got up and said,
"For the last time,
my name is Pete Buttigieg."
[ Laughter ]
Then organizers said,
"Sorry. Here's the real
Elf on the Shelf."
And then he got up and said,
"I'm sorry. For the last time,
my name is Dr. Fauci."
This is terrible.
Who's writing these?
That's right.
By all accounts,
it was a great time.
I mean, it definitely
went better
than Boris Johnson's
tree lighting in the U.K.
This is real. Look at this.
-Five, four, three, two, one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
-"Yea-- Ohh.
All right. Go home, everybody."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
Earlier today, President Biden
revealed his plan to fight COVID
this winter, which includes
free at-home testing,
a public education campaign,
and no lockdowns.
And everyone was like,
"Let's not rule out
day drinking so fast."
I mean, that's --
That's right. No lockdowns.
Biden must have felt the glare
of a million brides
planning their wedding.
Like, "Don't you dare.
Don't you dare."
Biden's plan
also extends the mandate
requiring people to wear masks
on public transit.
Then people riding the New
York City subway here were like,
"Yeah, can you also require
a mandate to wear pants?
Because masks are, like,
eighth on the list
of what's happening here."
[ Applause ]
"Ohh! Applesauce."
-"Don't grab the pole!"
[ Laughter ]
-But Biden did lay out
an ambitious goal.
By springtime, he wants
the majority of Americans
to know
how to pronounce "omicron."
-It's called the omnicron.
Omnicron. Omnicron.
The omnicron variant.
[ Laughter ]
-Ombicrombie and Fitch.
I read that President Trump
might have tried
to self-publish his memoir
to avoid getting
a smaller advance
than President Obama
got for his memoir.
Yeah, and Trump
is even considering
a few titles for his book.
For example...
-Oh, here we go.
-What's up, Mark?
-Let me guess.
You're gonna make fun of Trump
by saying a bunch
of fake book titles.
-I mean, yeah,
that was the plan.
-Oh, let me guess.
And then each cover
will pop up on the screen,
and people will see it
and laugh about it.
-Right. We often show graphics
during the monologue
to make our audience laugh.
-Man, I know exactly
how this will go down.
You'll start off with something
like, "Tweet Pray Love."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, then you'll
follow it up with,
"Oh, the Places You'll Riot!"
-Yeah, then you'll do,
"Are You There Vlad?
It's me, Donald."
-Yeah.
-Oh, oh, and after that,
you're gonna do,
"Fifty Shades of COVID."
-Yep. Yeah, these are all
pretty good examples. Yeah.
-Oh, and then you'll do one
that says,
"Lord of the Onion Rings."
-Wait, wait. No, no.
You'll do, "From Whom
the Taco Bell Tolls."
-Yeah.
And then instead of "Clifford
the Big Red Dog," you'll do,
"Clip-On the Big Red Tie."
-Yeah, I know.
But these are -- We probably
wouldn't do this many.
But, yeah,
these are all great examples.
-Oh, then you'll do,
"Nineteen Eighty
Four Seasons Total Landscaping."
-Yeah, exactly.
-Or a couple where you don't
even have to change
the title like,
"Pride and Prejudice"
or "Eclipse."
-Ah! Whoa, whoa.
And then you'll finish it off
with something classic like...
-"The Color Orange."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that how
it's gonna go down, Jimbo?
-Yeah, yeah.
You guys nailed it. That was it.
Yeah.
-That sounds like a fun bit.
You should do it.
-All right.
We'll do it tomorrow.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
This is exciting.
Tonight "Annie Live!"
premiered on NBC. Yeah.
It's been a tough year, so NBC
wanted to lift our spirits
with an orphan singing
about how hard life is.
Some business news.
Tesla just announced
two new products
that are kind of surprising.
First they released
a $50 whistle,
and it sold out immediately.
Then they released
a $2,000 ATV for kids
called the Cyberquad.
Take a look at this.
Or as parents put it,
"Yeah, here is a whistle.
Merry Christmas.
They were out of the quad.
Yeah."
Oh, on CNN this morning,
they were talking about
the dangers
of social media for kids.
And one guy had
a very interesting take.
Listen to this.
-You know, in your view,
how harmful
is Instagram to kids?
-Think a lot of parents
would agree with me on this.
I would you rather give
my 14-year-old son
a bottle of Jack Daniel's
and marijuana
than an Instagram
and a Snap account.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-His kid was like, "Okay,
so I guess I'll be drunk,
high, and on TikTok.
Perfect."
His son doesn't need
social media.
He's about to be the
most popular kid at school.
And, finally,
it's the holiday season,
and we're all getting together
with our loved ones.
But I saw that one family
in New Jersey
decided to try a shot-ski
with their grandma.
Let's see how that went.
-Put your lips to that.
-Oh.
-And you're just gonna shoot it.
You ready?
On the count of three.
One, two, three.
-Ohh!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Then Grandma was like,
"This is why I only do
keg stands."
We have a great show. Give it up
for the Roots, everybody.
♪♪
Oh! What a show we have
for you tonight!
His new album, "Body Language
(Deluxe)," is out tomorrow,
and he's a coach on "The Voice"
here on NBC.
Blake Shelton
is joining us tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's so fun.
We're gonna talk to him.
We're gonna play
a fun musical game.
And then he's performing
later in the show.
So it's gonna be -- Yeah.
A lot of stuff.
Blake Shelton tonight.
Plus, they wrote,
executive produced, and star
in "A Clusterfunke Christmas,"
which premieres this Saturday.
"A Clusterfunke Christmas."
It's so funny.
-Clusterfunke.
-It premieres this Saturday
on Comedy Central.
Ana Gasteyer and Rachel Dratch
are here tonight.
-Come on!
-They're my buds.
They're two of the funniest
people on Earth.
I can't wait
to talk to those guys.
Guys, we have exactly
12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member
an out-of-this-world
Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Now, since there are 12 shows
left, let's open door number 12.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's see it.
Wow. Look at that.
Oh, my goodness.
That is unbelievable.
Wow!
Can we -- Is there a back to it?
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
Oh!
It's got, like --
It's got, like,
almost like
a Pop-Tart back to it.
It looks like a Pop-Tart.
I like it.
Very, very nice.
Let's see who is going to go
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at your
seat number, please.
If I call your number,
come on down.
And, Quest,
can I get a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
295!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah!
-Whoo!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, I'm so happy!
You go over there.
Hello!
I'm so excited that you won.
What is your name?
And where are you from?
-My name is Nadeesha,
and I'm from Midtown East.
-Welcome. Thank you so much
for being here.
Well, where did you say
you were from, again?
-Well, I live in
Midtown East now.
-Midtown.
-Midtown, yes.
-Oh, yeah, but east of Midtown.
-Yes, the better side.
-Be more specific.
It's like,
"What's your actual address
so we can all send you things."
No, don't do that.
But here in Midtown,
it does get a little chilly.
-Yes, it does.
-And we're getting ready.
Do you have a
sweater or anything like this?
-No, I don't.
-Wow!
Would you like to try it on now?
-Yeah.
-We'd all love to see it.
Wouldn't you love to see it?
Here's this...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Are you kidding me?
You are a knockout.
Look at this.
Are you joking?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, walk the runway.
You got it. Oh!
[ Laughs ]
You are a star.
Give it up for our winner.
A round of applause.
Stick around.
We're playing
"Off Song Song Off"
with Blake Shelton
after the break.
You look gorgeous. I love it.
That's a rad sweater.
♪♪